greetings from podcast via little
[ __ ] it's Thursday the 17th of
the month we got a great show for you
today no more music
we're on Spotify now when I [ __ ]
around today's guest is my main man Josh
Adam eyes and the [ __ ] is
always [ __ ] here but before we
start the show is brought to you by
manscape the best in ball trimmers guys
it's two weeks into 2020 and you dick
still looks like the [ __ ] wolf man
you understand me have you got your
[ __ ] knob polished yet no because
you're a filthy [ __ ] animal that's
why manscaped is here to make you look
like a good [ __ ] friend I'm a good
friend man skaters here like a good
friend helping you clean up your [ __ ]
act they created the only tool to shave
your balls you ready it's called a lawn
mower 2.0 for a reason they threw away
the 1.0 and upgraded that trimmer with
skin-safe technology for mow mows in the
back that means it won't snag or [ __ ]
cut your little dick off all right do me
a favor get 20% off free shipping and
the free shipping when you use promo
code church at manscape calm
that's manscaping Tom use promo code
church for 20% off your first order gets
manscaped and keep those nuts nice and
clean and shiny you take this - nobody
[Music]
you see that thing my onyx music we did
today know that this guy on Grindr
killed a guy and strung them up and cut
his balls off and ate them it's guy
that's a way again off I mean you know
that's not getting bad out there you
know I'm gonna do it too oh yeah I mean
if you think about it though like
there's probably way just I mean that's
horrible I'm not taking anything away
from that this probably horrible [ __ ]
happening on Grindr every day I mean you
know two guys are disgusting and then
there's meeting up with some random guy
in a [ __ ] snow in a Red Roof Inn in
Tulsa you know I said this look at the
guy from never said nothing about last
year by the way Josh Adam lies
congratulations thank you Brian I will
show a billboard over
presents it's on Friday January 10th
that's the premiere but it's you can
find it on YouTube it'll be all over
social media so just go to my social
media page at Josh out of Myers or go to
the Comedy Central app and you'll be
able to find it don't give a [ __ ] no not
at all you know we have friends so I've
been told
I said I so confidently I know so I've
been told we have mutual friends that
are gay and then they live a different
lifestyle than us completely well you
have to consider Joey it's like you're a
guy so you have that natural guy stuff
so the way that we react to women and
how we're always thinking about women
you have to imagine now you're thinking
about men that way and it's in the woman
who's never thinking about you the way
you're thinking about the woman but the
guy is like yeah you want to stick a
plunger in my ass [ __ ] yeah dude I'm
into that and then that's what they're
doing you know so good for them it's
crazy
no no I ain't mad at nobody yeah it's a
lot of fun oh it's great I have a buddy
who he's not he doesn't have like the
effeminate voice so he sounds like a
regular guy and we drive down to San
Diego a new book oh yeah this is so hot
and he'll show me a pictures watching
porn
he's like hey look at this ass and for a
second you forget that he's gay oh it's
gonna be girls ass and this dude he just
said you have to keep this in mind dude
we're in Los Angeles which this is the
the best looking of the best looking guy
in the world you go to Pittsburgh
there's a guy at a bar right now that's
like a fact he's like he's like let me
get is he got some ugly [ __ ] two dogs
a bartender let me get a Budweiser and
put your balls in it real quick some
ugly gay [ __ ] in Jersey that's
what I'm saying New York they pick up
again in New York they get real you got
a challenge their closet easy and women
and guys so you don't know what the [ __ ]
you get you know when you suck that big
you know flavor and it could be whatever
yeah but it's really real like when you
see a gay guy in Texas like I know a gay
guy in Texas he was no Elvis he wasn't a
good-looking guy at all you know houston
I've met him any Houston has a big gay
area it's phenomenal still a big city a
big city they have a section of town
like DC has Dupont Circle and you'll
find all variations I did I forget the
name of this restaurant Fanny if you're
ever in Houston you've got to go to this
restaurant
Dingles no dangles oh it's I think it's
Maxwell opening a gay bar and call it
dangles that's the thing about a gay bar
I would love to open up a gay bar just
to get to push the name like I want
people signing petitions in my name if
you think they signed petitions in
Burbank against Burbank Airport yeah
wait till I come up with a name like the
flaming [ __ ] you know they open up
they open up of five guys there and I
was like ooh that's oh it's not gay I
was like no that's the burger place I
was like that would have been a perfect
day jaysus five guys who were lonely
what was what was this strip club is
still open
which one many men hi girls and one ugly
one oh yeah that's their motto and it's
what was their motto it was like 9999
attractive ones like three uglies is
that really you go to a java web site
I'm pretty sure that's that was like the
whole thing you know I mean hey they're
honest yeah but who would what stripper
would sign up to be the ugly one that's
[ __ ] that's the thing they don't know
they don't know they think they're the
hot one dude I've seen
when I DJ to strip clubs years ago it
because you they have to be that
confident sexual thing and so you can
find the hottest girl at the strip club
who makes no money but the girl that is
just like a four but and maybe a little
overweight but just [ __ ] is just in
her head she's the sexiest thing in the
world she make more money than everybody
girls all confidence I got a girl on
Twitter that I seen her you know his
Twitter's adding more more chicks doing
cans yo yeah alex muse has been on the
show I love onyx
I love woosh a she's a camera camgirl
why loves she's a young girl when I was
shooting The Sopranos we went out to
breakfast a couple times you know it's
like talking to a regular chick that
just shows a [ __ ] on a cam laying
around that's it nothing wrong with
there's nothing I wasn't mad at make
your money whatever as long as you're
not hurting anybody bro with the money
they're paying you nowadays you're gonna
[ __ ] go be a waitress
I stayed listen if I was [ __ ] hot I
was 22 I would [ __ ] put a mask on a
Wolfman and just show my [ __ ] I'll bet
for the hips I'd make a lot more than if
I was a [ __ ] Starbucks yeah putting
up with a lot of soybean for a drink is
you know yeah that's the [ __ ] truth
you know what we don't know about but
onyx muse about camp oh no so this is
chick okay
and one day she reached out like a man I
wish I made a comment and I looked I
looked at this stuff and she's a porno
chick but she's like 48 like knock it
off her ass is completely flat like you
know it's completely flat and she goes
you know she I'm getting back into porn
whatever so I typed her in and you could
see the difference she was here in 1990
hot [ __ ] was squirting you know she was
a [ __ ] fireball and something must
have happened you know she went to a
mental institution years came out and
she got back at the point and she's
putting people pictures up and every
time I retweet her people just tormenta
oh I'm trying to help what help us our
videos the people I please don't [ __ ]
retweet her I know more a buzzy solve it
speed up
Stevenson to me and then apart was they
retweet me retweet me I need all the
help I'll give you codes to my thing
yeah and she's the gangbang one okay
she's just a gangbang once she flies
into a town puts an ad in and [ __ ]
come to hotel 202 and suck my [ __ ]
and you see a bunch of guys lined up and
they just [ __ ] her it did it's getting
crazy
dude I've something crazy you know Steve
Randolph yes Steve Randolph did did he
wasn't I think he went to a [ __ ] like
that was shot he brought his like first
thing he's talked about it on like other
podcast so I'm not like outing anything
uh and he gave me the link to it because
like people found the link all the your
mom's house fans found the link and so I
said why I got to see it because I heard
Steve pops in it you don't see his face
but I was just like I just want to just
just to see it for a second and I go in
to watch it and there's like four vous
khakis there's a dude that was friends
with my roommate when I used to live
like one of the [ __ ] guys so it's
just saying and my friend I showed you
another buddy he was dude we gotta like
like like tell people and I was like no
no no no no no no this is for us we can
you know we have a funny picture of him
like just sitting there like a angry
face just holding his dick and I'm like
the guy's overweight but good for him
he works at enterprise you know what I
mean like I don't want to ruin this
guy's life you make your money anyway
you're gonna make you mind what's a
[ __ ] bukakke is like it's kind of like
a gangbang but I think more fun because
yeah you know there's a girl in the
center and every guys just preppin and
then one at a time they all just jizz on
her and at the end they all go [ __ ]
and I said oh we started in Japan
because they're into some freaky [ __ ] I
don't know about the ending well the
other the middle parts I might have
added them I might add at the [ __ ]
now it's really really disgusting and
disturbing that men do that you're just
talking about Judas Priest taking dick
and listening to that song that's one
guy one guy I'm not talking about a room
listen okay so I love you to death
okay I never ever ever want to see your
dick under no conditions later I'll show
it if you tell me that you're doing a
threesome and you got
chick and you're hanging out in the ass
I still believe you I'm saying I don't
like two dicks around me oh I don't want
a guy jerking off Nick I walked out once
I walked out once on a on a it would
have been and I said quasi orgy me and
my girl and a guy in his girl and they
were all on ecstasy we and I was just
everybody starting take clothes off and
I was just like I told the girls like
this is let's go in the other room I was
like I don't want to see other guy also
the guy was Neve Campbell's brother so
he looked like Neve Campbell so it's
just was like awkward you know I mean
I've seen the movie scream I like the
movie scream I didn't want to see him
you know
no not like I didn't want to see that
and would see him humping so when we
[ __ ] we look weird I don't want to do it
like with two girls that's one thing
I've had one threesome it was it was
great in my whole life but I di dia of
like like he said like do you watch some
of these like group sex things and like
they're going into it's like two girls
or two guys in one girl and like they're
like mush and their [ __ ] together just
to get it in the same hole and that's
it's too much it's too much work that's
just
yes I'm I think you have a jerk off in
front of the mirror what what I was used
to do coke one night in Vegas I was so
paranoid call outside sure I got the
jerk off in the bathroom and I caught
myself in the mirror jerking off okay
why why did we do that though why you
don't see yourself jerking off you look
a Jerry Lewis kid oh oh it's yeah we're
not it's like you [ __ ] [ __ ] do we
turn into like a goblin be like our
shoulders we have no neck we bend over
we got this weird creepy look on your
face I remember stopping I call it
that's what I boom I can't do this [ __ ]
no more
so I can't imagine doing it around four
five I did you know you look at a guy
like me you know and Joe Diaz is this
and that's just by judging them if it
comes to sex
you're gonna peg me wrong completely
because I was never that guy like I was
never that guy when I was a kid the big
thing in New York was to go to Plato's
retreat
what's Plato's retreat a [ __ ]
disgusting orgy really how are that you
paid five hundred to get in and you
promised to get [ __ ] and 200 idiots
would go there every night I'm gonna get
my dick sucked maybe three girls in like
a 99 guys yeah yeah I had the 10/40 club
which was ten to $9.99 to get you dick
sucked
plus tax is ten forty percent I went to
that one time and I knew that world
wasn't for me yeah I saw a porn that was
just you know porn now and porn when I
came from Cuba with two different worlds
oh well yeah one now has a middle of
beginning and ending the girl takes a
shower but when I came here from Cuba
not normal woman with doing porn there
like two days and being condemned like
they like listen the hospital stays and
of course you 1204 a year you just got
to make a stop and do some sex scenes
and then we'll take it to the thing of
the chick flick okay and they wouldn't
even know I mean I'm assessing they
weren't good looking so from an early
age I never really understood none of
that [ __ ] like there's a girl it was a
girl my hometown that sucked 20 dicks
two nights she sucked 18 one night and
like 22 the other night they called the
marathon woman when I was a junior in
high school it's 40 decks and I remember
going you know what I wish I was there
but then again I don't really want to be
there like that was like she came out to
18 decks burped who's next
and the guy he used to pimp around his
name was Jimmy Danny and he thought he
was [ __ ] Jimmy Page he drove me crazy
I always wanted to kill him I liked his
brother
yeah me and his brother the devil why do
you why didn't you like him just say
Jimmy that he was creepy he was 14 he
already had false front teeth he had a
long and I can't say I didn't like him I
liked them that family it's just his
energy it's creepy
yeah and he would always come around
with a guitar like those guys always
bother me so when I see a guy playing a
guitar like 2:00 in the afternoon when
the guitar is not necessary yeah there's
a guy that hangs out of this coffee shop
that I go to he's out front
that's necessary keep the guitar at all
should you be a little it's like the
guys on when you fly on Sundays they
walk on a plane with a guitar if you're
not Led Zeppelin check that [ __ ] day
cuz you ain't worth this [ __ ] check that
[ __ ] thing ok leave me the [ __ ] alone
if I don't see Robert Plant walking
behind you don't bring that guitar on
there yeah and then you want to sit in
coach and complain why there's no space
for your [ __ ] bass because you
playing the shitty band yeah that's why
you're in coach leave your [ __ ]
guitar off the [ __ ] plane it drives
me crazy what we talking all the guy
playing the [ __ ] guitar yeah other
buddy who would yeah so he would come
talk 38th Street Park with this quit
these like too [ __ ] freaky girls that
thought there were like the Manson girls
and he'd play the guitar at the park we
were shooting hoops I get irritated but
I liked his brother his brother was the
devil so you couldn't really [ __ ] with
him so what do you mean his brother just
he was just the tough days when we
weren't kids kids they call him the
devil like when we were 14 they called
him the devil guess what he is today
doing bangers in North Carolina our
house wife
you knew it at that age yeah you can
always tell who is gonna be yeah Mike
Mike Mike another deduction when my mom
died I ran with Mike at night it was
always a double cross he'd double-cross
everybody even you he was worse than
uncut gems he has the original uncut gem
yeah yeah he would he would double cut
you know yeah we would go make a move
and then we're picking up this and he
come back to the car he only gave us 80
bucks and then you see him with a
diamond ring the next day you
[ __ ]
you know he's one of those guys yeah but
he had a car he always played Aerosmith
get your wings there it is so I took
what I could I sure give me rides in
Harlem man so I took what I could from a
little bit and we do you know we used
his brother but this ain't the point was
that Mike I said what was his name Jimmy
Danny something like that one of the
Denny's like you would come up to him
there was a point where you would come
up to him and talk to him and he would
go you want a [ __ ] sure his dick
and you go like behind the car and she
would suck your dick and then he kept
doing that more and more and then one
night he took it to a party and said
suck everybody's deck if she sucked
everybody's dick and he took it to
another party and she sucks 22 dicks
that night and she come to school the
next day and there was nothing wrong
with her
from the outside and I remember sitting
behind her in class and just like saying
because they called a marathon woman
that was a street name marathon marathon
mara it's hard I could imagine how long
it would take to suck one dick to
imagine doing 22 in one night give it 16
I've never come yeah when you're 16 you
don't come you know you just sit there
with a hard dick like just in shock that
something well or it's the alternative
that they're they're just so excited
because the first time they have their
dick in somebody's mouth so it's just
like it's like I bet there was a lot of
quick poppers I bet there was life yeah
I bet there was a couple guys were like
this is my third one so I'm prepared I
forget years later looking at a high
school yearbook at a friend's house and
seeing her picture like smiling like
what the [ __ ] are you smiling about if
she's still alive I don't know I didn't
forgot a name thank God
I forgot her name we had up on Facebook
we had a family that was in the town
that I grew up in so in Germantown
Maryland they were called they were the
B crafts there was uh on Andrea be Kraft
I think was the daughter and there were
three there were three brothers all
varying ages older and I bought LSD from
the family once they were like they were
the degenerates you know what I mean the
B crafts and I remember one time like I
was at the Wendy's where we used to hang
out and smoke cigarettes and they were
there with Andrea the sister and like
literally she just looked so out of it
and they asked me that you won't get
laid it's like yeah you know hundred
bucks or whatever you can [ __ ] her this
is their sister yeah dude I remember
there was a girl at school too that that
I thought there was a rumor that she
would suck dick for $20 and what time we
got off the bus and we were all hanging
out smoking cigarettes at the bus stop
and I
I asked her in like a very not maybe I
was like yo how much would you bet what
did you charge if you had to subject to
somebody and she was like girls like
well I wouldn't do that and then and
then that girl she was like 20 bucks and
that got me so hard for some reason I
got so excited she was cute that's a god
I wish I'd Y bucks in that moment but
yes some some people are very just just
open the aundrea thing I think they that
that family was just such pieces of [ __ ]
and they probably got the the sister
hooked on drugs and then just for like
you're gonna be prostitute they're gonna
make money off for the other girl I
think just you know some people look at
sex in a different way you know they
look at it where it's not a big deal and
that's why that's where you get sex
workers there's some sex workers that
are just like yeah like I'll be a
stripper and I'll give you a [ __ ]
because I don't think anything of it
you're gonna pay me for it but I'll do
it you know yeah I just want to indeed
our buddy George Perez podcast and his
buddy they were cuz they do a podcast
him and his friend Eddie and he was
showing me on Instagram that they they
both work at strip clubs like strippers
they follow we'll just put on the
Instagram stories like it was it was the
funny thing was like a girl's got
Christmas presents to buy asses for sale
again just on her Instagram store dude I
had I remember strippers at the club
that would be like I gotta make rent
tonight so my knees are gonna hurt by
the end of it I'm sucking a lot of dicks
tonight that's just what they do do you
know what I mean there was a Mara Amara
wasn't one that just she was just the
[ __ ] queen man and she would guy
would buy a half hour from her for for
$150 and they'd go in and it's a 15
minute or a half hour is supposed to be
ten songs it's three minutes each song
right she'd be out in a song and a half
oh you a DJ a strip club I got hired at
desire which isn't too far away from
here in February of 2009 because
remember alex moore the 7-foot big dude
that used to hang out at the comedy
store used to be the door guy there he's
a regular there I think that's when you
weren't you weren't going around but
Alex I couldn't find a job
and I was going to like restaurants and
I was trying to get hired and I was
living on couches trying to be a comic
do it open mics doing what I had to do
to survive and Alex heard me complaining
and he goes he goes used to
he's like used to be a like a private
party DJ I was like yeah and he's like
dude you got a great voice man he's like
if I was you forget these restaurants
I'd go to a strip club he's like I bet
if you go to a strip club tomorrow go
out in the valley hit like six of them
because I bet you get hired at 3:00
tomorrow and he was right I got hired
immediately if the first club I went to
and I worked there it was off of [ __ ] it
was like it was off a Sherman Way I want
to say Bel Air by the club the desire
club that we were just not desired but
deja vu that we were just talking about
it's like literally on the next Street
East and I'm it was the shadiest place I
ever worked
it was long did you work there I worked
at that place from February until May
and then I went out of town for my mom's
retirement party when I came back they
took they hired somebody else and I was
like dude I got all my shifts covered
they're like we didn't think you were
coming back I was like I literally said
to you I'll be back in four days and
they they [ __ ] fired me and then I got
hired in the Spearmint Rhino
first place I went to because it was
always funny anytime I went to a strip
club to apply and I was like I was like
yeah I was like I'm a DJ and they'd be
like yeah we don't need one and then I
go oh man that sucks and they go wait
wait wait you got a great voice we got
to put you up there it's like you were
born to do this and I go up there and I
just be like oh yeah y'all go in the
back and get you dick mush and they're
like all right you working Tuesday how
long did you work at they jaw who for I
didn't work at a job boo I work I worked
at desires and desire worked out from
February to May Spearmint Rhino I worked
at from buck from June of 2009 until
January of 2016 I didn't work at that
same club I moved on to a different club
but I you know dude I I had worked there
and it's like you're I was building my
career and it really started taking off
and then it became this level of hating
the job so much because I wanted to quit
and just be a comic and I'm doing all
these festivals like Just for Laughs and
I'm um you know and play open and for
BER
and every once in a while I remember I
remember one weekend I was I jammed with
burr at at Madison Square Garden before
he headlined we rented all this
equipment I jammed there and the night
before that I'd sold out a show at
Gramercy doing the goddamn Comedy Jam
and then a week later I was at the club
in downtown LA being yelled at by a
stripper so I developed this like
horrible opiate addiction just [ __ ]
because it was in downtown LA so I just
every time I was driving to work I just
stopped by fifth and Broadway pill alley
jump out of my car I had my liaison at
call him say yeah one let me get five
blues and he'd meet me in the car give
him a hundred bucks and go to work and I
had to like dope myself up so I could
just get through the shift and then it
was we we sold the show to Comedy
Central and in November of 2015 and then
January 2016 my I was really really bad
off with pills and I kept I didn't call
out from work but I kept getting my
shift covered only were Thursday and
Friday night and I was making bread too
I was making you know five to $1,000 a
night I was making five hundred thousand
a night working two nights and I
remember I called out one shift because
they had me working on Christmas I did
work Thanksgiving and Christmas cuz
Thanksgivings on Thursday and Christmas
that year fellow I'm done on a Thursday
and I got my shifts covered and then two
days after Christmas the the manager
called me he's like hey man he's like
we're gonna take away your Thursday and
Friday nights and give you Sunday and
Monday and the money would have dropped
exponentially I got would have gone from
500 to maybe 50 to 75 maybe $100 a shift
and I just said yeah I think I think
that's it and I was dating a girl and
she had some money and so she was like
yeah I'll pay your bills until I had no
bills so him he was like rent was like a
thousand bucks that was my only bill and
and then a few months later I started
touring so then I just never went back
but I went back a few times and I just
went back recently just to cuz I've
driving by I was on the five and you
look right at the 5-10 interchange
that's where the club it's got Dame's
and games is and I was like you know
what I was like it's been like three
years I haven't been back I just want to
go in there and I went back to the same
[ __ ] all there
every single like the same same door
guys same deejay and they're just beaten
and bruised and just if the club is not
nearly what it was when I worked there
when I worked there it was a [ __ ] atm
I showed up I had so many hustles it was
like you want this song hundred bucks
you want to go on stage and let me skip
all these girls you guys split that
money that guy I had so many little
hustles didn't deal drugs but just and
and it's just like it blew my mind and I
now when I go there now which is rare
but what I have I go in there so I see
that world so I can say to myself never
go back man for Cass I know five years
that you were for the strip club
what did you see what did you I mean
yeah you saw some beautiful women you
saw Ted you saw [ __ ] asses women
walking around naked probably you could
probably get your dick sucked once a
shift but after a while you become numb
to it you see so yes what is it that you
saw and that made you you see a [ __ ]
dirty ugly pain
I saw the worst of people see I saw the
worst of what of what money can do to
people what people are willing to do for
it I'm not just talking about sex I'm
just talking about like the selfishness
the whole thing ego it's just you're
getting see that's the thing is that
like people like you know Ryan Sickler
and Jay they have the podcast a crab
feast and I go on there and I tell these
stories from my life not so much a strip
club but just life and like you know
they in a kidding way will call me like
a dirtbag in a guy are you this and it's
like nah man I was just learning I was
learning in life and I made a lot of
mistakes and I can look back now and be
like dude I'm a good person I take care
of my friends and family I'm not selfish
I don't leave with my ego so the worship
club world was not for me I'm a
sensitive guy look much like you we were
listen to that song like I felt that
that almost got me and it's like it's
like I I I only did that for survival
but it was like it I never let it change
me but it but it was like if I could
have like if I never make it and I think
about that
make if I don't create the jam or I
don't you know really just you know
start doing my own things I could still
be there and some people like George
George loves it because you and George's
Interbike he's just a fun guy that drank
some parties and and he's cool with all
the girls for me man it was like I went
in there for money and it made it
brought out the worst of me man and I've
seen you know I've seen some girls go in
there that are like I'm doing this for
now and I'm gonna cuz like maybe the
economy crashed or they [ __ ]
something happened or they got went
through a divorce and and then they can
go in there and compartmentalize it like
this is a job and I just leave it here
I'm the party girl here but once I leave
I have my kid or I got this and I pay my
pillows I like to go to school and then
you have these these some girls and
people that like this world is the only
world that they know and and they thrive
in it cuz they don't give a [ __ ] who
they rip off they don't give a [ __ ] you
know what they do to get ahead of you
you know what I mean I've seen girls
drug other girls I've seen so they could
get their customer I've seen fights
fighting over nothing
like nothing and it just like and I
gotta play the [ __ ] soundtrack to it
you know what I mean it's it's it was
such a such a sad place for some place
that's supposed to be so much fun it's
there's so much sadness I day this I
like I said I'm what the Mel lands in
when I was a kid I saw a girl put her
Galliano bottle of [ __ ] and bananas are
Tina Tina
that was great when I was [ __ ] 16 and
17 and then something happened to me I
don't know I just strip clubs became and
I'm not talking about that I'm not
taking my high moral Road there was just
something that didn't do anything from
me to be honest it's like going oh
you're not gonna show me your [ __ ] the
wings ain't that good yeah you know as I
am I want to see your [ __ ] I don't want
to see cleavage you know I'm already I
already went through puberty yeah so for
me it just became nothing and then I
started dating a stripper well they
started picking her up
I would pick her up and I got into her
world I would talk to her and you know
the day the stripper has a man it eats
you alive because no matter what they
tell you do you know I guess through lap
dances really
and you came home with $2,000 unless you
did lap dances for retards I wouldn't
give you no dollars there are just no
hierarchy yeah I get you and they have
regulars and I'm single and I'm looking
for a boyfriend in time come next
Wednesday and that's yeah that's you
regulars it's a hard it's a lot it's a
long it's the long game and then the guy
finally after 20,000 he realizes there's
nothing that's why they don't want your
boyfriend ever picking you up don't have
your boyfriend pick you up yeah cuz what
happens the guys in the car dreaming
about you and awesome he sees [ __ ]
your loser boyfriend because that's what
you have yeah you have a loser boyfriend
when you dancing that allows you to do
that or they even considers that that
means that he's laying somewhere doing
drugs and he's not doing the right there
they're pimping there it's it's a fun
thing that's that's like I saw that time
and time again so I lived with her in
Seattle and I loved her I loved her but
it bothered me and it was something that
I just for me to move forward I just
couldn't think about she would come home
take a shower
I wouldn't ask her nothing she'd tell me
to help her count the money I drop a
couple 50s on the floor and put my sock
you know because she's not all bright
she wasn't no [ __ ] Phi Beta Kappa
even though today she has a master's
degree tell her I love the debt now
which tight friends but while I date her
I went through a lot of like you have to
check your emotions and then I would go
pick her up and I'd see the people who
would be at those places and it was the
same guys like hoping that something's
gonna happen you're like you could have
been on a dating site you know you could
have done this and this and this and
then I saw something all right so we got
here we lived
trailer on Fairfax and then we broke up
and I moved them with Stanhope and then
we got back together and by that time we
had an apartment [ __ ] Hollywood
Boulevard and I would pick her up so I
would driver at 7:00 shoot do my spots
do my spots at the store then I'd pick
her up in the quarter - she worked on La
Cienega what's the one loss she had a
guy that's been there I know I know it's
like bailar go right and it's owned by
the same guy seven bail the same seven
veil
cuz she could've could've switched yeah
have you been to the seventh veil my
place a [ __ ] dude I went there one
night cold I think that's a coconut
place that's wrong helped out yeah it's
to smell that place it's small I got
abortion clinic in there so we [ __ ] in
that place smells like an abortion
clinic it really doesn't have this smell
that is just rusting yeah dude it stays
with you oh god I have to pick her up by
that place in the quarter - I go back
then I'm waiting and I never got out of
the car she just knew she would text me
and she knew it'd come on ten minutes
and I would sit in the car whatever I
didn't have a cell phone back then no
this one night she ran out and she put a
bag and the thing and she goes come on
and you have to see this and I go what
he told on she goes you gotta see this
we went through the back and in LA they
have a 6-foot rule do they not in the
same in Hollywood
well yeah on the stage onstage exam 97
if you got a private dance
you used to dare and I stood here with a
rope in front of me and when we walked
in God West God rest his soul it was
Chris Farley a week before he died
saddle another by himself
with a dinner jacket on and like a grey
shirt on but the grey shirt was covered
and sweat he was just sweating from the
blow whatever
he was he's doing speed balls my face
was red his Chiefs were be red and he
was sweating so much his hair look like
he was putting grease in it and all he
was doing was he had a stack of money
they had just ripped the bands off he
was just taking them and all the matter
and laughing and man I just looked at
each other I'm like I'll guess I'm not a
Chris Farley fan dumb luck yeah that's
how bad Chris Farley looked he didn't
look like he was even being a nice guy
oh you think I've been up for like three
days maybe longer it was like anger it's
like me just going okay you want the
money get the [ __ ] out leave and he was
just throwing money at it i sat there
for maybe three or four minutes and me
and my girlfriend left maybe [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah but that whole while I dated
that girl I felt that darkness so Joe
Rogan tells the story that when I moved
here I wasn't funny or sudden one day I
got funny when I broke up with that girl
her bad energy she had such what they do
for a living you know we were talking
about dream stealers before people who
steal your dreams you know it's like
when I worked at the sports betting
service and I would call you up and say
let me go three for four I know I don't
have him the information and in
meanwhile you really did lose $75,000
you really did you really took my
information in bet and you really did
borrow 30 from your mom and 40 from your
father and 60 from your grandmother's
retirement account to put this bet in
you know how bad of a karma that one is
when I worked at that place and today
out of all those guys I worked with the
sports betting service pretty much all
something is not right with them one of
them came to one of my shows and I go
how these guys doing I don't see them
they're in the bottle what's-his-name's
wife left him at guy he went broke
because it's like if they were playing a
scam
and I think sometimes strippers have
that energy this girl today is
successful she's working she's got two
kids I'm the Godfather to a holdest boy
you know I keep in touch with her but
her life has been nothing how kids
remember her with 15 men I know since
the kids were born she's at 15
boyfriends hmm
so the energy was so bad that she had
around her that once she got him my life
like in a second is being around me away
my whole life changed
I could same situation it was like I
lost 40 pounds of energy like thought
like my thought process didn't have to
think about her anymore
dude if you're dating somebody that's
depressed or negative and you like their
I mean you take that I take people's
energy so in the sense if you're if
you're in a good mood then I'm in a good
mood do you know what I mean and if
you're sad like that's all like when I
go home my mom's kind of a negative
person like I love it at death but it's
like it's it's it just brings me down to
where it's like like I start feeling
that way and but now since I started
meditating and and and doing all this
reading and [ __ ] that it's like I can go
home and separate that and be like okay
she that's her energy I don't have to
take that but you go to that if you're
dating somebody that is a that is
negative or living in a negative world
like that you have to believe that
energy is real and then you're pulling
from that man dude I was dating a girl
that was depressed
and I was depressed after I had the TV
show I'd never been more depressed in my
life than when I had that TV show
because I'm for a multitude of things I
saw it survivor's guilt for my friend
dying I was just upset of the way the
show was made and and I couldn't enjoy
one second of it and isolated from the
world and I admit I was dating this girl
and man we just isolated her and I
together because two negatives when
you're depressed and she's depressed two
negatives make a positive
do you know what I mean so she's a fun
hang we're having a great time and then
I went through my little existential
crisis where I was like [ __ ] man I was
like I haven't been doing stand-up like
I used to it's like I I don't know what
I'm gonna
do but I always have stand up so I got
to dive back into that and I started
doing it and then she started saying to
me she's like are you gonna go out again
tonight and I was just like I was just
like I was like sweet how you got go I
was like I that's a problem you can't
grow like there's so many there's a lot
of women that at first they don't really
know what comedy is you know 30 days
it's great I like the hotties son
it must be great living with him oh it's
a barrel of laughs wait the another
double I'm calling you from Florida what
are you doing I'm in with Josh adamantly
we're at a PF Changs
[ __ ] show it's great it's always
great we won't be home till next Tuesday
and you're that carrying two babies
cleaning out a little box my comedy
career ain't no [ __ ] fun yeah
so whatever woman you decide on or mate
if you're a woman you decide on they
have to be alright with that fellow in
the beginning you have to set the rule
like that second all day like listen
[ __ ] I'm out five nights a week if your
parents come to town I don't give a [ __ ]
if your parents want to go out to dinner
I don't give a [ __ ] if your uncle dies
in a car accident nothing to do with me
and it's very hard for somebody to
accept that oh yeah dude not any woman
is gonna accept that but back to your
statement I have a different situation
my wife is a positive person but it's
not what you say it's how you say it I
could just say to you eight they just
blew up Tower three oh my god they
bought tower three you don't saying yeah
my wife is the second yeah you know I'm
about to leave in the morning I'm about
to go to Miami I'm just getting the
Olbers outside yeah and my wife we go
this torrential storms of Miami and I'll
tell her knock it off it's just one big
[ __ ] deal
and if you know anything about the news
it's probably sunny in 38 because they
show us the [ __ ] my my daughter's
Godfather lives in Fort Lee every night
they tell me how the frigid conditions
in New York tonight and they make one in
Fort Lee and the ladies stand out and
she and even shake
she's wearing a windbreaker glad having
a jacket like a windbreaker itself and a
dolphin yeah [ __ ] that's kind of
what my mom's like too my mom is she
blows everything like she just like
lines up with the voice that's how my
dog that's how my wife was raised like
everything is a panic like I still
remember when the towers were getting
hit I woke up - oh my god oh my god what
the towers got here I know if we can I
tell this story I was at the store
Monday night and it was the week that
[ __ ] were having the home run races
McGwire and Sosa yeah ok and and Paul
Mooney was down a Monday night he kept
saying they ain't going up that hill
[ __ ] break the record I'm telling you
they gonna let that little [ __ ] break
the record if you ever saw Paul Mooney
that's how he would talk ah yeah
everything was racist
yeah he was talking about Barry Bonds
because they're never gonna let that
berry bar they're never gonna let that
[ __ ] break the record what something's
gonna happen so I went home with that
mind and I woke up to my wife going oh
my god they just loved our poor I'm Emma
go away can I thought [ __ ] Paul
Mooney was right
they're not gonna let that little [ __ ]
break the record because they cancelled
all the games hitting get his head a
little bit so how's this new [ __ ]
podcast was great it's great oh god I
want you to do it so [ __ ] bad we
gotta find you a record I got a
simulates so it's I have a PI look I
went you cool you contacted me here's
the problem now what did you do ZZ Top
right because I for some reason I
thought you know what ZZ Top fan yeah
but you hit me with an arm that I
haven't listened to in 25 years
you hit me at a time in my life when you
know who has the time yeah now you don't
listen to a [ __ ] album and really
absorb it so I felt like anything else
in life you know you're a pilot right
Josh out of minds in your life you fly
for United Airlines then why the [ __ ]
you write in the movie about
fishing oh I can't get it I'm having
writer's block yeah cuz you're not a
fisherman did you ever think of that
you're a pilot write a book about a
drunk pilot that gets out of plane and
jerks off did women in the camera in the
[ __ ] bathroom that's what you know
yeah it's the same thing so for me to
live like but I like the two aspects of
it I like the aspect of getting
introduced to an album that's a great
thing that's going you know what I am
gonna take in Joni Mitchell from Josh
out of Myers but I need a week of Joni
Mitchell sure I need a week to put that
album on smoke my reefer well that's
what we need to do is that I just need
to send you the list for the next like
shade that's big bad was he here no no
but I looked at the top oh you did yeah
you did call me and talk about that yeah
I wondered and I was like there's no way
for me to listen to what I want to
assess it I gotta keep hearing it yeah
I'm hearing it in hearing and then going
wow that's amazing that they put metal
guards right behind that song yeah it
goes right into it and this mist
then I gotta go online and read about
the recording sessions and have a studio
burned on fire I love that yeah I wish
every guest again what you're talking
about right now when you're talking
about
not Exile on Main Street but what would
be album when they put sympathy for the
devil nah I don't know that one stay
Beggars Banquet
okay yeah Beggars Banquet the studio
brought down while they were taping
beggar's banquet after they did please
allow me whatever that song so you
understand me that's what you know I'm
gonna go in there prepared I want to go
in there saying you know what the first
three albums prior to this Frannie
whatever your last name is played the
bass but on that ounce you got knocked
up and they replace to it Rudy Sarzo
yeah well that's why you well what's
what's good and I love that you I love
that you
you want to do the research - but I do
all the heavy lifting so all I ask is
the guests you know look at the list of
the Rolling Stone magazine's 500
greatest albums right and then I want
them to pick one hopefully they're
picking one that is already in their
heart you know what I mean that they
grew up with and so because then there's
like a whole story behind it where I was
like I was 13 I remember the exact
moment I heard Appetite for Destruction
and then this happened and then this
happened and then we talk about when I
used to rape women I would put my
discman I put that on it I had on the
shock thing so it wouldn't skip while I
was raping before I'd rip them I listen
to one way or another from blondie and
I'm family
that's what I would like that raping
somebody but I'm talking about like you
want to go back to well it's great but
it's also great what's on making love
the first time so I just want you I want
the cast but see there's it's here's the
thing when you have when you're going
through a list that is that it's it's a
huge it's not just me it's like music I
haven't heard of like wish I started
doing the podcast because I I was going
through my I went through a midlife
crisis when I turned 38 I know that
sounds funny but if I'm lucky I get
another 38 years you know what I mean
every day is a [ __ ] gift and I was
like I want to feel the way that you
felt when we put that song on by the
platters I want to feel like that every
[ __ ] day and musically I was so
tapped out and so I remember like you
know my buddy Angela that passed away
loved Rolling Stone and he was like we
always talked about that 500 greatest
albums list they made and I was like you
know what I'm gonna listen to an album a
day and I'm gonna do it for 500 days
because I want to experience or like you
talking about beggar's banquet I've
never listened to that I know Rolling
Stones but I know the hits
I've never dug into an album and I was
like that's where the real music well
the thing about the stones is the reason
why I mentioned the stones is because I
say we discuss black and blue they went
to Jamaica record that out
the stones used to go to different roles
yeah dude do they have such names such a
little history amount about how whenever
we know they rented whatever the house
in France Exile on Main Street yeah cuz
they will wanted for tax evasion and
[ __ ] England a little heroin and they
had a high I don't know if this is the
exact story they sounds like it they
have said they did they that's how come
our main street is such great out
because it came from
that's so good we need oh sweet Virginia
is one of the greatest songs I've ever
heard in my life but that's the thing is
that I I like there's so many good
albums out there that I've never
listened to because like most people and
like like you and you and all of us
we're stuck in our ways with the music
that we listen to do you know what I
mean
like whatever we listen to and when we
were in high school in college for the
most part that's pretty much what we
still listen to and I was listening to
Stone Temple Pilots and Guns and Roses
and [ __ ] Radiohead and all the [ __ ] I
love the Beatles and I was like do but I
want to experience what's been made and
instead of looking into the future of
what's coming out now there's all this
great music that's already been made and
that list is the greatest recorded music
in the history of mankind that's been
put onto Wow but that's according to
Rolling Stone wow that's typical panned
out or Led Zeppelin's they said didn't
like the listen now but they but dude
like I think they've got like five
albums in there yeah they do but nine to
wait yeah that is why Peter Grant having
us on the Rolling Stones and I am NOT
saying that smack some Chinese people
[ __ ] I'm a Chinese guy from almost
famous oh yeah yeah I'm not saying that
that list is definitive in the sense
that you know there are when you get
like from where I'm at right now cuz
right now we're at 438 question yeah has
anybody gone on the podcast and said
Josh I appreciate you give him this out
it was total garbage
yeah Kyle Kinane well how Kinane did
public image Ltd's you know them so it's
a post-punk band I the lead singer for
the Sex Pistols started a band called
ltap il I'm sorry yeah PIL so public
image Ltd
and here's the thing so I put it on and
it's gonna the album's called metal box
I put it on cuz I listen to everything
at least eight times I give it the
respect it deserves because I understand
that when you listen to an album
sometimes takes a few times before you
get it so I really sit there and I dig
in and then I do one long pass where I
sit with headphones on and I read the
lyrics and I write what I liked I pick
out the parts that I like you know my
read I have these researchers that give
me all the facts and give me the song
meanings and all this [ __ ] and then I
kind of like put it all together and
figure out how I'm gonna talk to my
guests about each song and I put on put
up yeah and I go this is the worst piece
of [ __ ] I've ever heard in my life why
is that on this list it shouldn't be it
sounds like a mess the editing is bad
the mixings bad there's no melodies the
lyrics are [ __ ] stupid and and then I
was like I don't know how I'm gonna get
through this eight times but I said I'm
gonna because I have to because I want
to give a real honest opinion and so day
three still hate it
day four hate it even more day eight
comes and at this point I've listened to
it
you know seven eight times and I went to
bed and I woke up the next morning and I
started humming this song which was
impossible for that album because
there's no Melody's song called pop
tunes and I was just like Bob dinner on
Tuesday ski bill on dude do and then I
put the record on and I sit there for a
second and I go that's the greatest
album ever made man she's that's the
that's the post punk [ __ ] brew it's
genius
it's [ __ ] gee that's what I'm saying
that's why I don't think it's fair also
because I need time no and I want I need
to clean my room I need to smoke dope do
what I did I need to write yeah leave it
on I need to fall in love with a hook
and then somehow just you read a book
that is [ __ ] highly credited it's a
New York Times bestseller your dirty
pages in and every every [ __ ] page is
a death sentence and you put the book
away you know it's the same thing it's
the same thing with [ __ ] music for a
guy like me if I gotta listen to
something like I can't stand that [ __ ]
why do good white people like who's that
who is that lady talking about the white
dude that white people like those that
like that's a serious war like this dude
who's one in the [ __ ] right now he's
in the lead for the Hall of Fame I can't
stand Dave Matthews in the room with me
how he died was because he bought his
bus hey so got the kiss of death
I don't like Dave Matthews at all how he
did it I don't how can you not like it's
marching that's uh no no it's our but
she it's not I'm not putting on the
[ __ ] idiot
people love is when they think they're
deep when people white people think that
is national he's no Asian on Springs
he's from Jersey you have to excuse me
with parties we walked in and said
Springsteen's come along to turntable
you walked in everything I turn and I
had friends that were going Diaz and
break your Springsteen out really I
thought everybody in Jersey London steep
are the Jersey you know they should be
only mine gentle fair job Florentine
isn't it I'm not gonna take growing up I
was not a Springsteen man
I like 10th Avenue Freeza I like Born to
Run yeah now I like the river now he is
later there's a couple things I like
when I was in raised to like Springsteen
and I tell you also I was raised to hate
when I was getting raised Hills because
nobody was shut the [ __ ] up about the
[ __ ] now I can imagine yeah you know
I mean I mean you you couldn't go to a
[ __ ] show like man I want to see Devo
last night [ __ ] cool is showing the
[ __ ] in the world
yeah but the Beatles are better wait
till they get back together really
everybody busted your balloon with the
[ __ ] Beatles I want to see black
[ __ ] last night they were great yeah
well we threw the Beatles get back
together the day John Lennon got shot I
laughed on all those [ __ ] faces
together now what do you do now what do
you do now I remember the first John
Lennon was
even [ __ ] dead 12 hours there was a
portrait of him in high school and
somebody had already put an extra room
with a spray paint that's how [ __ ]
cold brother we were at mines goodbye
God
listen I come from my hometown that I
could call you a racial slur and be
mothers of West combat boots and she's a
[ __ ] and you'd probably walk away with
walk away from me I came from the town
where we could smack each other over Van
Halen
but you said what [ __ ] Van Halen -
sucks but you know what so does your
mother know that was a kid that was from
my block yeah after my mom died and I
move from giving that terrorist the
Bendis true me and I lived on 81st
Street and we were all happy metal fans
but this guy actually thought he was any
Van Alen we loved that
what do you mean he played guitar sorry
just he just yeah yeah okay yes I was
living Halen ethos yeah I love I love
him
I still talk to him he came from a poor
family of five brothers and his dad was
short and we would bust his dad's ball
to eat some pizzas and [ __ ] the fluff
sent me a beats yeah that's the bastard
yes order food in somebody's house
caller ID with some cabs to his house
one day we said we call the priest from
Our Lady of Libra and we go mr. Tabasco
is dying go over there and say your last
but the guy misses the basketball he's
doing awake imma be used to torture him
oh my skin [ __ ] the guy I don't talk to
Ray that much anymore the older brother
worked at the inspection but he had one
brother that was a van Halen fan and we
all used to get together in joy soon as
you see him just bad-mouth van Halen
broke his face would get red he'd come
out with albums he break guitars I mean
we would haven't gone crazy on that so
we like Van Halen
the Pete you know it's funny because I'm
I'm I'm I'm a van Halen fan in the sense
that like I love John Paul of Panama I
only know the hits really but the people
that loved Van Halen
everyone that I met that's loved they
[ __ ] love van Halen man it's it's
it's you know you can't say anything bad
about them or I love van Halen one for
van Halen - men's Armada women and
children hey you know like I like that
one song it's like that's Sammy Hagar I
got busted with coke at at Sammy Hagar's
Cabo Wabo I'm talking about David Lee
Roth it's the back the first time was
amazing
Van Halen - was men's a more women &
children first was okay but the problem
was they had to picture him hanging in
the middle when you opened the album
there was a poster of David Lee Roth
hanging in a corner with chains that's
it the album one in the garbage
anybody's house we went to they had that
album got in the garbage
dad look too much damn when they came
back then they think it was diving down
and I really sucked
Oh coming out around the world are you
ready yeah it's like them when them
[ __ ] came out with that mean
Street I don't know that one cuz I won
their video wasn't MTV when you go home
tonight I can't play cuz they'll take it
down yeah after this show you watch van
Halen 81 if this is love that was one of
the early rotation videos on MTV and you
Sammy know if this is that's a different
one oh yeah you're way behind the
[ __ ] spectrum you better really get
it together right right it's out no dude
first of all the reason that now here's
why I'm doing it up would say Sammy for
stories I'm talking about here's why I'm
doing it this is why I'm the perfect
person for it cuz I feel music like you
do I feel it man in my soul dude I talk
about on stage now where it's like there
is nothing better when you got a song in
your heart everything burns brighter
you're just you know you're walking
through the life with a little bit of
peponi step you know cuz I listen to a
song and if I love it
I listened to it 45 times in a row I
can't I mean over yes we're dudes wait
right now my side and Tyler and Tyler oh
god that's my favorite song right it's
just so big it's such a good man
and it goes into Chris Cornell Cochise
goes into [ __ ] Ryan asked Ryan up -
aw and then it goes into fella black
days that's really we we with BER we
played - or at the goddamn Comedy Jam
and we were like we're marina said he
said we're about do a Soundgarden fan
and rebus like yeah and he goes it's not
one you all know and I mean we [ __ ]
crush that [ __ ] it's all like offbeat
and just for me it was fun because I was
singing for him and and it's like to be
able to sing like a Chris Cornell cuz
like no danger you can't dude it's like
you stand with that dudes voice is
perfect
Dean has one of the best voices I've
ever heard ac/dc he's right on oh I've
got every any time he's done the jam I
went to his birthday parties where he's
done like the full albums all the way
through and I just sit in the audience
in awe where I'm like Jesus Christ man
that dude was made to be a rock singer
so all props they had man he's you know
I'm more of like I said like a Scott
Weiland you know what I mean like I sing
in that like hotel towel and he's more
like like I can't I can't do that I blew
my vocal cords I have surgery on him a
few years every singer make them smoke
weed yeah but you said sometimes like
the reason the reason I'm doing the
podcast and I'm getting the audience to
listen to this music is because there's
so much great music that everybody
thinks I knew but I don't
so I'm at me and the audience are you
know each week we're listening to like
went this week we just did with Neil
deGrasse Tyson we did Sam Cooke live at
the Harlem Club 1963 I only knew a
change gonna come stand by me those
songs by by Sam Cooke this album has
like changed my life it has made me a
better person because you're you find
out the story behind it in each
episode that he that he fought for like
it wouldn't play and set a nun you know
what segregated clubs and like this was
his attempt to like really you know like
show like the the audience's what he
could do and and then they shelved the
album for [ __ ] 30 or 22 years because
is you know the record label thought he
was being too black in it but it's like
perfect and I posted on on on my
Instagram that this is the homework that
everybody needs to do and I can't tell
you how many of the fans are like or
people that I know are you this is like
thank you for letting me listen to this
but also like dude this is one of the
best records like there's so many albums
that we don't know about that that
everybody should listen to because
listen I don't I'm not saying they're
not gonna make another classic you know
but you know in all honesty you you get
down to the final like 200 on that list
and that's it you're talking you're
talking Jimi Hendrix you're talking on
notice reading Marvin Gaye your favorite
band The Beatles [ __ ] the Beach Boys
like [ __ ] Pet Sounds I mean that's it
those are the greatest albums young we
have homes they sold this year who does
the binos of the Beach Boys is the first
time since 1987 that vinyl had also DVD
by thousands that hundreds of millions
it's backed yeah and I'm very happy that
it's back I'm very happy yes in the
cornhole system you know the guys like
you find sure that they were
interviewing people or me but yeah yeah
Christmas Eve or two days after
Christmas Oh me but did great this year
with albums and people like I you find
treats in there and I'm like listen you
don't find the truth until you open up
you see the pot seat that's when you
know that was a real album cuz that's
you know that was the moister breakups
await our time yeah dude you got the
album you brought it home you your mom
works so five dad works till five we get
high we break the thing up you put the
almond and we each got a turn reading
the [ __ ] lyrics and uh and the cover
it was a thing
yeah they wonder why nobody's buying
them cuz you just download it there's no
story you say nothing we start we used
to take my dad's these some of my dad's
records and we
you see we broke the wheat up you
breaking up up top because you have that
shitty swag with you and so the seeds
would roll down yeah yeah yeah and the
weed ah that's why when you go too far
when you now that's what you're looking
for I guess that was by I go to our
doctor and I turned around I was going
to turn around and go to the one I'm
right up the corner from Porto's well
they have a lot of time league records
oh wow yeah I never I never I need this
I need to get more records man we've
talked about them and two days later
what's his name one in there they said I
heard I'm Joey Diaz the show I don't
even know was it well I did the show
with the the punk rock guy that was on
Sons of Anarchy playing white
supremacist he didn't know and I guess
every Rock every Rollins didn't know
that was there I go Henry it's been
there for [ __ ] years
I guess [ __ ] two days later what's
his name one in there cuz he didn't know
there was a record store he was - Henry
Rollins his podcast the other guy don't
look at the time to think about the
beautiful people it's Marilyn Manson
Marilyn Manson went in there because
what he heard Henry Rollins mate talking
about so I went in there two days that
he was you know Marilyn Manson came here
said he heard about the church I was
like [ __ ] about god that's so cool that
is so cool man well I don't think you
realize that I've said this to you is
like you're you're a guru for so many
people like you're you're like Eckhart
Tolle a like you don't I don't think you
realize there's like a total I wrote
these books it his whole background is
about being present it's like it's about
getting out of your ego and just being
present and being able to enjoy this
moment because that was you know
something that I dealt with for years
I'd be hanging out with guys like you
that I look up to and burr and and you
know and Burton just whoever and I would
just be in my head like oh god I hope
I'm not act like an idiot I hope I'm
cool but that's just I wanted people to
like me instead of just being there and
being in the moment so what he does is
talk about like how yeah we've got all
this baggage but [ __ ] that [ __ ] like
leave your pain body aside and and just
be living the now because that's the
only moment that you have and so this by
thinking like that you you start
realizing that this moment right here
because that we don't have the
past we don't have the future all we
have is right now this is the best
moment of our lives do you know what I
mean because it's the only thing that's
palpable I can touch this I can do that
can't go in the past and grab this water
bottle so when you wake up in the
morning and you hit a bowl and you write
I want you to wash your balls and [ __ ]
it and go out there and attack the day
you don't understand that's like the
most positive [ __ ] in the [ __ ] world
to tell some people that that normally
aren't gonna read Eckhart Tolle so
they're getting these positive things
from you so you don't know it but your
[ __ ] goodness that I write what I
tell myself
exactly exactly listen there's nobody
lazier than I am
there's nobody [ __ ] more scared to go
out you know I'm surprised I got on a
plane I mean I really help guys I wish I
was lying to you guys and telling you
how many fears I have but if I had the
time to think about them I wouldn't be
Who I am I wouldn't be a human being I'd
just be a scared person living in the
house playing Monopoly by himself that's
what I was built to do when I was a kid
I loved doing models
who builds models nerds who want to be
alone and don't want to be bothered so
everything I do I gotta force myself to
do you don't force yourself to do
something by going well I really don't
feel like going over the Fannie's I'm
gonna stay here you go no Fanny cooked
mashed potatoes and soft meat lo she
went on her [ __ ] way for you today
you know she probably shaved a monkey
get up stop being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
cuz that's how you're acting you're
acting like a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
you mean lights I want to cancel the
Comedy Store every night every night
every night yeah at a corner a time like
what excuse can I come up with I don't
have to go so 28 years of doing comedy
still saying to yourself what excuse do
I have to tell myself not to go down it
and this has been going on since day one
what's the excuse gonna be tonight why
am i canceling this open mic and you sit
there on your couch and you go I'm gonna
cancel all sudden somebody has to it's
like I didn't have a parent so
to be my own parents you know what but
you're a lousy Sat this [ __ ] you're a
[ __ ] loser
that's the Chucho Diaz you're a [ __ ]
losing a GD you went to prison you got
no time to sit on that [ __ ] couch you
gotta earn this on that couch get the
[ __ ] up and get your ass in this ball go
to the store and then you go home then
go home and get on the couch cause you
deserve it but go to the store yeah you
know me tonight I walk to that coffee
machine and I'm gonna be honest with you
guys I do a four [ __ ] expresso shot
two is for [ __ ] I do four to get me
over the hill to go on stage see y'all
like a lunatic for 15 minutes and then I
run home and I [ __ ] hide I don't go -
yum yum donuts I don't go to [ __ ]
nowhere to hang out what do you think is
I'm a scared little [ __ ] boy so with
all those things I post is what I'm
saying to me that day completely how am
I gonna get out of this hostel you know
what it's Wednesday the birds are
chirping the Sun is out it's time to get
your dick sucked everybody wants
everybody wants to go to heaven but
nobody wants to [ __ ] die people
people asked me for advice all the time
about how I created this or how I did
this or how I got this sold and I'm just
like yeah it's like you put love into it
and if you if you don't think about the
reward you just enjoy the world love you
love the work about the rule or every
everything there is no reward beat the
reward is the fact that I get to wake up
every day and do something that I love I
love stand-up comedy I love listening to
music I love hanging out with my friends
and people that love me and even people
that don't love me I love hanging out
with them too I'm just a cool yeah you
know I'm beyond me but that's the thing
is anytime I give somebody advice I'm
just I'm just hearing myself say it so I
can remind myself now you got to work
hard you got to skip all the [ __ ]
you can't lay on your ass because if you
lay on your ass and nothing's gonna get
it done you have to you have to work at
the work and work nobody does nothing
that they want to do yeah nobody nobody
wants to do dick all four of us in the
Rob Halford where he wants to do anguish
all four of us right now which are all
wish we all remember that rich kid in
high school
the z28 when he was 16 and he had the
pool and we were all like look at my
[ __ ] parents they're losers I got
stuck with these [ __ ] stiffs
I got a [ __ ] floored [ __ ] jacobi
you know a tree that's missing the door
I gotta close the door with a bungee and
we all wanted to be that [ __ ] rich
kid remember yeah and we didn't want to
copy Kalani yeah we all have that one
name yeah they went to they did
everything we all wanted to be that
[ __ ] person well guess what me too
but God didn't throw me that hand yeah
God threw me and he made me ugly he made
me [ __ ] need you're adorable away
then you gotta go out there and you
[ __ ] yeah nobody wants to do three
causes should they do trust me I know I
love my job Mayo visiting your job and
binge watching my clothes and some
Chinese chick rubbing your feet what
would you rather be doing do you love
your job that much well I guess you got
me there okay dude I got it I got a dog
that is like it's a sweetest Doberman
you ever met in your life like this I
can show you a picture of it would just
melt your heart she's just the most
loving creature in the world and there
are girls that are like I like let's go
out on a date and then I look at my dog
and I'm just like yeah I think you know
after my setup right he's gonna go home
and and just chill because that that
this is that's what I want like you know
what I mean like like I don't have time
to to go out of date find out that we're
not gonna get along I already can I
already can say I'm probably not gonna
be with this girl
it's just I've gotten everything in my
life down to a place where it's like I
do what I want to do when I want to do
it and I don't like you know put myself
in situations that I don't want to do
and that's not saying that I'd you know
every night I want to go out and do
stand-up I I do always want to go out
and do stand-up but there is that moment
where it's like it's just like dude I
could I could just stay here and just be
with that dog and just what I just know
because I gotta work but I also but the
thing is either with me
I love stand-up comedy so much that on a
night that I don't have a show I get a
little sad I'm like guys I mean I could
have nothing to hold a good say I could
have nothing the whole day but if I've
got a five minute guess spot somewhere
or I'm
I'm doing [ __ ] you know a bar shell
out in Tustin like that gets me happy
and the rest of the day just burns a
little bit brighter but I've gotten it
down to the point now where I working on
only things that I want to work on like
I work on the podcast to yesterday's of
the podcast game room comes out every
Wednesday on Spotify on Spotify but on
every platform but it's a Spotify
original podcast and it's and it's great
one day you will do it we know that
burrs done it this week we had Neil
deGrasse Tyson we've had Wanda Sykes
we've had dude this is the coldest [ __ ]
dude is that we've had actual musicians
that have worked on the record like we
did the Pogues rum sodomy in the lash
and we had James Fernley who's one of
the founding members of the pogues he
was the accordion player and he just
gave us the whole [ __ ] story we
excuse me
good anybody who plays the accordion
wanna hang out with her right [ __ ] off
he was actually David Gilmour from wants
the [ __ ] got a place yeah I get it
I gather he did not play the tambourine
the accordion is a little bit bigger
than the goddamn tambourine let me tell
you something that [ __ ] playing
guitar and then they showed up with an
accordion he said who could play this
and he goes I'll try and then he saw
rolled him up good guy you can glaze
guitar with like a bunch of other guys
in like the Dropkick Murphys I know
you're but it's like he's the [ __ ]
man dude but we had we had when we did
the Devo episode we had Josh Freese on
who was the drummer for Devo we've we've
like and what's so cool and this is this
is where it gets where the podcast is
just getting better and better and
better is right now we're doing albums
that a lot of people don't know but a
lot of people that people are listening
we have good numbers people that listen
these records they're hitting me up
think oh my god this album is I never
thought I'd like this and it's blowing
my mind and we're getting great guest
but we've got a Booker for the show and
so we're reaching out to people like
Colin Farrell and Jason Momoa and and
like you know I'm trying to get Fred
Durst for Nirvana and just and we
reaching out for people so big because
in my head when I get down to the final
10 like I'm gonna have
like I'm getting Oprah because I'm gonna
get Paul McCartney for sergeant pepper
because it's gonna grow and it's just
we're you know certain albums people
that might not do podcasts are like dude
this album by Led Zeppelin means so much
to me that I have to go on and talk
about it because I love it it's a part
of our lives like music is a part of our
lives more than more than the you know
like a you know your parents sometimes
just that you connect with Jude Appetite
for Destruction changed my life you know
Stone Temple Pilots core changed my life
man and I wouldn't be here if it wasn't
for those two wrecks I would be here if
I didn't watch George Carlin on comic
relief with my dad when I was six years
old so you have that there's something
about art that just encompasses us and
so we're reaching out to these huge
names saying hey we want you to do this
record now and they go no no no no no
I'm not doing it now two years in two
years when this record comes up 100%
I'll be there so it that's what I know
and I respect and that's what's cool
because we're finding the people I'd
rather have you do a record that is in
your soul and and that cuz that means
something and that means something to
the audience when I add when I had Joe
Joey DeRose on for EPMD strictly
business one of the best one of the best
episodes we've ever done cuz that dude
had noose everything about it he knew
all the facts and all the history and
that's what I want but also I do like it
cuz I there's Joey that's it's hard
sometimes to find like you know somebody
for [ __ ] echo and the Bunnymen so I
got a like booked it because every
episode comes out on the bucket movie
you brother I tried you for ZZ Top
[ __ ] you know that you listen
to me Annie Lederman on that woman she
she actually did she actually did
[ __ ] what did she do she did cheap
trick in color because we had I was
gonna have this comic-con not gonna say
his name but cuz he's gonna do another
one eventually but he was like yeah I
love cheap trick and then he listened to
in color and then he goes I hate this
record I can't go on there I was like no
no you gotta come on because you hate it
that's great like I love that like it's
sometimes it's about the discovery I
might just go on just a [ __ ] tear
band uptown like
you know what I would love to call me
when you get prints listen princess
princess princess Maya Rudolph or get
Maya Rudolph Furst
I wasn't someone like Prince how can you
hate Prince
I don't like brothers oh I thought you
did oh you want to do it too I think
you're talking about call me when you
get Prince
obviously you can't get him cuz he's
[ __ ] dead oh that's the [ __ ] joke
what's the way you cut this part out
really the website
ah you can it to find out the show the
show is called the 500 with Josh Anna
Myers go to the 500 podcast.com and
what's cool is we get every guest to
make like a mixtape and then we turn
into a Spotify playlist so we can get
inside the musical mind of Joey Diaz and
Bill burr and see what they really
listen to episodes come out every
Wednesday it's it's my favorite thing in
the world man
I love making this do I spent six hours
yesterday breaking down little Wayne's
lyrics from the car to three and it made
me realize I ain't [ __ ] so all I know is
just just join the [ __ ] movement man
like what school was even if you don't
listen to the record I use the facts and
the song meanings to interview my guests
so I'm like oh they were talking about
this here have you ever experienced that
so it's all encompassing it's it's like
we work really hard on it and join the
[ __ ] journey man because it doesn't
end until May 31st 2028 mutha [ __ ] I
love you [ __ ] don't forget this
weekend I will be Friday night Fox
Stephen Bakersfield Saturday night tower
theat in Fresno and the second show the
first show sold out it's having that
capito and we got a second show I let
9:13 and land on the 25th of January I
love you Josh Adams I love you more than
you know q4 coming on thank you now for
a word from our sponsors all right I
want to thank Josh Adam Meyers don't
forget to catch him on Bill burr show
it's probably on YouTube now on comedy
central.com but I want to thank manscape
getting the church to you every week you
know why because they're the best in
ball trimmers they got stuff you never
even think of [ __ ] they got think
of the perfect package that you get the
lawnmower you're like joy what's the
lawn mow the lawn mower was a tool that
was created by manscape to shave your
[ __ ] nut sack and to clean around the
dick pole to keep everything smelling
tremendous you understand me they got
this thing called the perfect package
that you get the lawn mower with a pair
of anti chafing boxes that won't scratch
your sack plus they're gonna throw in
the crop preserver or deodorant for your
balls and the one I like to revive but
let me taste them
it's a spritz that tones and refreshes
your nutsack and keeps it cool - my nut
sacs are all [ __ ] wrinkled - looks
like a bad elbow I put some [ __ ] and I
put some Reviver on my nut sack forget
about it
it looks like Dana White's head nice and
[ __ ] smooth with the perfect package
you'll be smooth as a [ __ ] snowman so
what the [ __ ] are you waiting for
you want to get your dicks up this 2020
and you're walking around with that
[ __ ] stink [ __ ] bomber ears
between your legs no more it all ends
today why cuz you're gonna go to
manscape and you're gonna tell them
listen uncle Joey says I want the
[ __ ] lawnmower
I want the Reviver and I want the
[ __ ] crop preserver so do me a favor
get 20% off and free and if you do the
perfect package it's the only way to go
so do me a favor get 20% off and free
shipping when you use promo code church
at manscape com
that's manscape com use promo code
church to get 20% off your first order
manscape keep your [ __ ] balls clean I
want to thank [ __ ] Josh out of Meijer
I want to thank the [ __ ] but
most importantly I want to thank you
guys don't forget tomorrow night
Bakersfield is still tickets left me and
Jorge Perez Fresno sold out and then the
following weekend on the 25th
[ __ ] Atlanta with my man Steve
Simone we're doing two shows the first
show sold out the second I'll show you
still got tickets lip
who do you think you're [ __ ] with I
love you guys have a great [ __ ]
weekend and we'll see you Monday morning
tip-top Magoo ready to [ __ ] go stay
black